welcome to my talk keeping secrets with
JavaScript today I'm going to give an
introduction to the Crypt API
I'm Tim Talbert I've been working for
Mozilla Berlin since 2011 I usually work
in the desktop version of Firefox and
there on a variety of different
front-end features mostly written in
JavaScript I discovered the web crypto
API a few months ago and started writing
patches for the stuff that was missing
in Firefox our implementation has since
remarkably improved and we now support
most of the exciting algorithms that are
listed in the spec I would not call
myself a cryptographer but the work I do
here is reviewed by very experienced
people that helped me look out for the
right things and make sure I'm not
having too much fun with NSS that is our
native crypto library anyway so you
might ask why do we need a crypto API as
the web platform is becoming more mature
developers are asking for it
you can either provide an API or watch
them use crypto libraries written in
JavaScript plugins or add-ons are not an
option either fall for full web stack
devices like for example a Firefox OS
phone where we could use the vac RIPTA
API to securely store the pin of your
lock screen we could write a password
manager web app we can basically
securely we can basically secure or
encrypt any local storage on the device
but also websites can make use of the
web crypto API to encrypt data before
sending it to the server via TLS to
avoid any trace of sensitive data and
server logs there certainly are a lot
more valid use cases but they would
probably fill another talk we have a lot
to cover today so let's dive headfirst
into the example that will guide us
through the talk I do indeed want to
build in a Notes app with you because I
think that's just a great and simple
example if you don't have to talk about
the UI anymore everyone knows what these
apps look like and most of you have
probably already written one our app
will be a little different though as we
will be using cryptography
to protect against various scenarios to
follow the example you should be
familiar with type 2 rays and you should
know how to work with promises at the
end of the talk you will know the basics
of the web crypto API and see that it
helps us implement a notes app with a
safe and local storage with only a few
lines of code and we will achieve all
that without using any external
javascript crypto libraries and it will
work in Firefox 33 in chrome 37 so as I
said before we don't care about the eye
so let's start by taking a closer look
at the storage
I picked local forage that is a small
wrapper that automatically chooses the
best supported back-end for you that is
hopefully next TB but it might also be
local storage local forage is great we
can directly pass any data and be
automatically get an async promise based
API for free this is how we would use
our storage API 10 it doesn't really
care about the particular format we
could pass whatever even plain tags but
as maintainer of the API we immediately
start to think of a few few things that
could go wrong here let's say we are
varied about silent data corruption not
a particular about losing data but about
the wrong data being stored we certainly
don't want the corruption to change the
amount of money we owe Alice and so the
first thing that comes to mind is to add
some sort of integrity checking and as
it turns out cryptographic hash
functions are excellent at providing
integrity I assume that most of you have
probably seen hash digests before when
downloading big files from FTP servers
like cannibal into DVD image he would
download the you would calculate a
hashed I just over the file you just
downloaded and then compare it to the
hash digest that is given on the website
to check for corruptions and if the file
was corrupted you would throw it away
and redownload it in our example we will
be using sha-256 that is a cryptographic
hash function of the shadow family given
the exact same input hash functions
always return the same output if only
one bit changes a good hash function
returns a totally different result
variable length data goes in and fixed
size data comes out
that is 32 bytes or 256 bits for a shot
256 for a good hash function it should
be hard to find two different inputs
mapping to the same output or as a
cryptographer would say it should be
hard to find a collision for this hash
function the evap crypto API provides a
simple digest function we just passed
the desired hashing algorithm and to
data to calculate a digest form it takes
an array buffer and it returns a promise
that will also resolve Ranieri to an
array buffer all cryptographic
operations are defined in the namespace
window decrypted subtle cryptographic
operations can be quite expensive so all
these methods return promises and do
their work asynchronously implementers
can thus easily move all the heavy work
off the main thread subtle by the way is
supposed to reflect that many of these
low-level algorithms have subtle usage
requirements and those need to be
satisfied in order to provide the
required security guarantees or verted
slightly differently they really want
you to know what you're doing because
it's easy to screw up I would have maybe
suggest that the somewhat more blunt
naming but that ship has sailed
we will see more API examples later but
let's start using the digest function to
provide integrity for a note cell this
is our basic storage API that I showed
earlier and we will start by modifying
the safe function now instead of only
saving notes we also want to store a
hash digest for integrity checking using
promised all here to store both the
values makes the code a little nicer
because it waits until all promises
password are resolved and thus let's
caller know when we're done saving now
we of course need to compute the digest
for the given notes argument and deaths
call crypto table digest with sha-256 as
the hash function and pass the notes as
diva crypto API operates and typed
arrays only we should probably change
our site or our safe function signature
to make it clear that it takes ray
buffers now instead of any JavaScript
value so now that we stored everything
we need to know for integrity checking
let's implement the actual check and
take a look at the load
we will use promised that all again to
read both the notes and the hashed I
just and as soon as those allotted
people and to compute a digest of the
notes we just read from disk and using
the compare function we then compare
that to the hash value we read we read
from disk compare here is basically just
a simple function that takes two typed
arrays and simply compares them byte by
byte and if the digests are equal we
resolve to the notes that we read from
disk or otherwise we will just
implicitly resolve to undefined using a
cryptographic hash function we have now
solved our data integrity problem and we
can easily detect accidental corruption
we are however not at all protected
against deliberate changes an attacker
can compute the digest just as we do
this is especially easy with the
browsers dev tools nowadays but even
without that it's not really a challenge
it would be great to somehow combine a
secret with the hash function so that we
can prevent deliberate changes what we
are currently missing is authenticity
when reading data from disk we want to
be sure it was written by someone that
knows a specific secret and if the
attacker does know the secret they can
convince us that the data on disk is
genuine H max or hash-based message
authentication codes are a cryptographic
construction that is excellent at
providing both integrity and
authenticity this construction uses hash
functions in combination with the secret
key to compute a valid authentication
code for any data we does need to know
the secret key and the hash function we
will use for H mark will be shot 256
espy's as we have already seen in the
previous example now whereas hash
functions only take a single input and
return a digest H max take a keys ball
that is the secret key that we need to
know to compute develop mak combining
the data and key inputs these functions
return a message authentication code and
we can use this code later for integrity
and authenticity checking given the
exact same data and the exact same key
the H make function will always return
the same message authentication code
this looks quite similar to how we use
digest before but this time we use the
sine function and additionally pass a
key argument the promise returned will
resolve to the message authentication
code for the given data under the given
key and instead of comparing the digests
byte by byte manually now we can use the
verify function provided by the API we
just pass a key the Mac enter data and
it will then resolve to a boolean that
tells us whether the Mac is valid for
the given data under the given key so
let's update our storage a sec function
to use an HTML instead of a hash digest
we first replace the digest function
with the sine function pass HMAS the
algorithm and the secret key
both the notes and the macro computer
are stored in a back-end and know that
our safe function now takes a key
argument to verify the stored Mac upon
loading let's update the load function
we don't load a hash from disk anymore
but a Mac and instead of computing a
digest and comparing those manually we
can now use the verify function to
compute a Mac and verify that at the
same time the promised return by verify
will resolve to a boolean that tells us
whether the Mac was valid for the given
data under the given key and if all goes
well we resolve to the notes that we
read from disk or otherwise we will
again resolve to undefined our load
function takes a key argument now as
well and I hope you're wondering where
does that key come from the most
straightforward thing we could probably
do is to just prompt user for password
and use that as the key right the
problem is that passwords are not
cryptographic keys they have a lot less
entropy and they don't look like random
at all just think of how they're
composed that consists of printable
characters only maybe some numbers and
mostly the same special characters like
punctuation marks that means we can't
use passwords directly but there is a
way to derive cryptographic keys from
low entropy keys like user typed
passwords and that is what we call a key
derivation key derivation is the process
of deriving a second key from a given
key
the verb cryptic API provides the derive
key method it expects the key derivation
algorithm to use the base key to the
right from whether the algorithm that
the derive key will be used for whether
the key is extractable that means
whether below exporting it to a
different format and what we plan to use
it for signing verifying encrypting and
decrypting and so on the promised
returns will resolve to a crypto key
object and that key can then be used for
any cryptographic operation as given
within the constraints of the last three
parameters in our example we will be
able specifically use the pbkdf2
algorithm that is an acronym for
password-based key derivation function
and was especially designed to derive
cryptographic keys from low entropy user
typed passwords so how does this work
looking at the parameters passwords
obviously the password as given by the
user the salt is a non secret random
value that defends against rainbow table
attacks rainbow tables are pre computed
tables with hashes for all popular
passwords and their variations by using
a random salt you would have to pre
compute the table for every possible
salt value and for example when using
Adrian and bytes as the salt
we just need to pre-compute 2 to the 64
of those tables which makes an attack
practically infeasible because for most
of the people it's just too much data to
store now in our case an attacker could
just take the public salt value we have
here and start the dictionary attack
where they would simply try all deposit
all popular passwords and slight
variations until they found our secret
key and to slow down this kind of attack
we specify a number of iterations high
enough such that say instead instead of
a million passwords per second an
attacker could only try a few hundred
passwords per second with 5,000
iterations that's given here the inner
computation of pbkdf2 would be executed
five thousand times over and over and
that's all down the key derivation but
also the attack by roughly a factor of
5,000 it is important to note however
that this does not protect us from wikis
if the user chooses one two three four
as the password the attacker is still
going to be able to find it very quickly
so let's start using pbkdf2 for Oh notes
up we create a function called the right
key that we pass a cryptic key
containing the user's password and we
pass a salt the function takes the salt
as an argument instead of randomly
generating it because we only want to
generate generate it once and then store
it we need the same salt to arrive at
the exact same key later again the
derived key will be used for HVAC we
will sign when saving and verify when
loading let's now create two more
functions for both of the arguments
starting with the password key creating
a key that contains two users password
is actually really easy we can call
generate key with pbkdf2 is the
algorithm as the algorithm usually
generate key would generate a random key
for pbkdf2 however it would open a
native dialogue that is asking to user
to type a password that is pretty nice
as the user's password will never make
it to JavaScript and a clear and only
the native parts of the browser know
about it and the API will only return a
key pointer back to JavaScript lastly
let's define the gets all function we
want to generate the salt only once and
then store it using crypto dot get
random values we generate a few random
bytes to use as the salt get random
values is a cryptographically secure
pseudo-random number generator and the
only method that is not encrypted at
subtle and the only method that is
synchronous the type to right path so it
will simply be filled with pseudo-random
bytes and to prevent a rainbow table
attacks I talked about before we pick
eight random bytes as the salt here an
attacker would thus have to pre-compute
two to the 64 of those huge tables
putting it all together we can now just
use the three functions we defined we
first retrieved user type password and a
salt which is read from disk or
generated on the first launch given the
password and the salt we can now derive
a cryptographically secure key using
pbkdf2
and finally pass that to the storage a
safe function and that will then use it
to generate an H Mac for the given
buffer
this is what our storage contents look
like now we start a soil to derive an
HTML key using password-based key
derivation upon saving we used that
derived key to compute an H MEK and
store it and upon loading we use the
drive key to verify the data by
comparing H box that is pretty cool so
far
the only thing an attacker could now do
is modify o store data and make us
discard it we could probably implement
some kind of online backup mechanism but
that doesn't feel great as long as the
data we store is still plain text and
it's probably not great either that's
simply having access to a computer
still exposes all of our notes we
finally arrived at what I assume most of
you think about when hearing the word
cryptography
that's encryption we want secrecy and we
achieved that by encrypting our notes in
a way that at the same time at the same
time provides integrity and authenticity
unsurprisingly we will use the encrypt
function offered by the other cryptic
API to encrypt data we pass decipher to
use for encryption the key and the data
to encrypt it then returns a promise
that resolves to the encryption of the
given data under the given key calling
decrypt with the same key and the
encrypt the data will just give us the
plaintext again AES the advanced
encryption standard is a very popular
cipher we will use it in a special mode
called the Galois counter mode AES alone
does only provide secrecy but it doesn't
provide protection against corruption or
tempering and GCM will do exactly that
for us AES GCM does not only take a key
to encrypt data but it also takes a
lance
that is the number only used once and
somewhat similar to the salt we saw for
pbkdf2 before the nonce is used to
implement randomized encryption if we
use a new random nonce every time we
encrypt then even the exact same
plaintext will always yield a different
ciphertext sofie's safe without changing
anything then destroyed ciphertext will
still be different every time because in
the world of cryptography we don't even
want in tacit to know that nothing has
changed the result of the encryption
will be an array of bytes that
the ciphertext with the message
authentication code appended that means
we don't need to separately store the
Mac anymore but just like just like the
salt for pbkdf2 we now need to store the
nonce to be able to properly decrypt
later we switched from using HTML to a
es GCM for encryption with us first have
to update our derive key method we
created been talking about pbkdf2
earlier here we simply change the
algorithm that we plan to use the derive
key for from H Mac to a es GCM and that
key will now be used for encryption and
decryption using AES for our safe
function is actually quite simple we
generate random nonce using get random
values it is important that announce is
long enough to say 16 bytes so that it
is highly unlikely we generate the same
random nonce twice and what does use the
same random loans twice to encrypt we
switch to using the encrypt function
instead of the sine function l and pass
a s GCM and the nonce as parameters we
then store the ciphertext and the nonce
to be able to properly decrypt later the
next thing we now have to do is to
decrypt in the load function the load
function now loads the ciphertext
and the nonce from disk and passes those
to the decrypt function if integrity and
authenticity can be verified the promise
will resolve to the plaintext notes and
if the verification fails the promise
will be rejected and we just resolve to
undefined again that's pretty much it we
now have a notes app that safely
encrypts its data with a user type
password and the best part is we
achieved all that without using any
JavaScript crypto libraries and with
only just a few lines of code the
examples given here work in Firefox
although it's still hidden behind the
preference and they work in Chrome
although chrome unfortunately does not
support the whole password-based key
derivation I talked about yet to make
sure everyone understands how we got
here let's do a quick recap I hope that
for those of you who could not follow
the code a few diagrams will help
ten things better the first step we took
was to harden our simple storage by
adding integrity checking now we did not
only store denotes themselves anymore
but also an additional shot 256 digests
to check for corruptions when loading
and if the to digest is not equal we
simply discarded two notes the second
step was to add authenticity checking
now we could not only detect accidental
corruption but also deliberate changes
we here stored two notes and the Mac
computed using the HTML construction and
if the Mac did not verify under the
given key we would again discard the
notes at this stage we did not have the
kea to use for each macaron so the next
logical step was to look at
password-based key derivation using
pbkdf2 we prompt the user for a password
and use that to derive a cryptographic
key and in addition to the nodes and the
Mac we now also have to store the salt
so that we arrive at the same key every
time when deriving all right that
doesn't work I do this and as the last
step we added encryption to our Notes
app we started solve for key derivation
the encrypted notes and denounced the
nonce was the random value that changes
with every save operation it was used to
implement randomized encryption if the
encrypted notes do not pass integrity
and authenticity checks under the derive
key we will just simply discard them
again you can find the code for all
intermediate steps we talked about on
github we're almost done but I didn't
want to leave you without the obligatory
reminder that before using the API for
real-world applications make sure that
your largest knowledge is sufficient and
ask for review from experienced peers
cryptography is hard but I'm sure you
heard that a lot already and we have all
seen it and especially the last year
what I actually wanted to do is to
encourage you to brush up your crypto
skills go out there and help make the
web a better place I would be super
happy if the Stockard motivates you to
learn more about
hagh Rafi these two courses for a
tremendous help for me and a whole lot
of fun cryptography one actually started
a week ago again and you could still
join it if you want it kind of course
also watch the YouTube videos whenever
you want but they're not quite as dense
and take a while to watch I will post
the slides on my block later and they
will have links for more dev table of
links to more information if you want to
talk to me about the back crypto API
Mozilla or anything you can find me
hanging out at the Mozilla launch later
thank you